who comes in with an on base streak of
eight in a row in the sox
five and four records so johan has done
very well for himself in terms of
running long at bats he's 10 for 32 this
year
breaking ball hitting the sky left
center field well struck back at the
wall and off the fence
robert's on his way into third and
joanne moncada pierces one off the wall
and the socks are in business here in
the first monkana almost goes out of the
ballpark hits this one not on the sweet
spot but hits it well enough to hit the
wall and here is jose abreu 1-2 wrapped
on the ground to shortstop robert's
coming home abreu drives him in moncada
to third and the sox have a one-nothing
lead yes money grandal has a chance
runner at third one out
in the air right hand side
gamel toward the line is underneath to
make the catch monkatta tags from third
and he's on his way home grondahl drives
in the second run and the sox jump out
to a two-nothing lead here in the first
so two up two down here comes christian
yellets o2 pitch that one's hit well
center field that is way back robert on
the run and that one is off the wall
yell it's on his way to second with a
stand-up double you stay right on it
against the lefty and that's exactly
what he did and fastball up and
christian a good high ball hitter and
pounds it off the bottom of the fence
and center gives the brewers a scoring
chance with two outs perhaps and that'll
bring up avasyl garcia garcia rips one
fair down the left field line that's
going to go to the wall
in the score is yelich garcia on his way
to second back to back two out doubles
for the blue crew it's a nice swing by
garcia rips it down the line the brewer
is able to come back with one in the
first new pitcher is on the mound for
chicago matt foster is in relief of
carlos
interesting you know diamonds thrown to
baseball pretty well velocity was down
a tick here today but
he was efficient 26 pitches 22 strikes
but he will exit
and logan morrison is going to grab a
bat so craig went to
he couldn't stop himself strike three
and matt foster
has one out in the third
it's going to be corbin burns
in a piggyback with brett anderson two
to one chicago runner at first garcia
on the ground jam shot jerko to second
out there throwing a first and it's in
time for a double play and nice feed by
jerko the arm for here a strong throw to
first the brewers have their lead man
aboard so it'll be ben gamel now the
lefty on lefty match up he drills one
into center field base hit arcia will
turn and head to third gamo's on his way
to second
and he is in there camel with a double
back-to-back hits for the brood crew in
business in the fifth rc on third gamble
on second there's a very dangerous
batter casting hira intentional pass for
hira so that's gonna load the bases with
one out and bring up christian yellidge
the one two slider called strike three
right down the middle and yelich could
not get the bat off of his shoulder as
fry strikes him out looking
and that's gonna be it as jace fry he is
responsible for the three men standing
on the base paths but he is being
replaced by the right-hander steve
seashell now avi garcia trying to
salvage this potential big inning for
the brewers they are ready to run on the
bases garcia gamel
on the ground and it's in the left field
of base hit harcia will score here comes
camel the throw to the plate cut off a
two-run single for avi garcia the
brewers take a 3-2 lead boy that's a big
hit for garcia
and then ben gammon running on contact
able to score socks are trailing four to
two so a runner in scoring position for
chicago abreu coming to the plate
high fast ball rock to center field
garcia back at the track it's gone
bring him home and bring a tie to the
scoreboard
jose saw everything in that last at bat
and there was nothing left for burn this
ball club has battled back for a top sox
lead by a run here we go top nine
bonkata
3-2 in the air right field
way back to the wall and out of here
enough carrie to clear the wall
camel had no shot at six to four socks
second big home run of the night juwan
monkatta takes him deep his second of
the year
he's got three hits tonight leaving him
a triple shy of the cycle runner at
second two out yelich in the game
on the ground right side nick's got it
sucks win six for your final score
in a vivid intense baseball game
the sox have won